[Music]
what's up everybody
where's a quick stop the mecca ground
zero of the view askew universe now
we're at 64 Leonard Avenue the end unit
which is going to be transformed into
the new smog Castle Jersey style as you
all know it takes a kingdom to build a
castle so watch Ricky d turn it into the
castle come on in
[Music]
so this is the spot the new location of
the smog castle New Jersey he's Coast
style so we just walked through here is
a little bit of a foyer area this will
be a beautiful black box brain walls
black ceiling black floor little red
speckles fancied up I'm going to put
some lights some memorabilia some
artwork on the walls gonna be a cool
spot up there is our stage gonna happen
mr. Kevin Smith's gonna be here once a
month hopefully we all know how Kevin
rolls but hopefully once a month you
gotta be here people do right now it's a
little bit of a mess but this is the
inner workings of the new smart castle I
got the walls up I got the stage up we
got some electric going
every week I'm gonna come back and give
you an idea a little update for what's
going on a little bit of painting a
little bit of electric a little bit of
flooring a little bit of memorabilia so
once all that stuff starts happening you
guys will get the updates every week and
please tune in and when the SModcast was
open with shoots for the end of April
sorry to interrupt your programming but
the smart castle has been postponed till
June 20th because of the corona virus
now back to your scheduled program it's
going to be good
we're gonna be doing live podcast
audience participation we may even do
some weddings you know do some comedy
nights we're gonna do film festivals
anything you guys can think of for the
view askew universe we're gonna do it
alright we're gonna have a blast please
join us for the next couple episodes
peace
[Music]